disco delivers affordable science-backed
skin care treatments to your home the
Disco Starter Set helps guys fight oily
skin and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated I've had great results with it
you'll get 30 percent off at
letsdisco.com Pacman the link is down
below
well I hope everybody who celebrated had
a good Thanksgiving I will talk about
mine on today's bonus show very very
compelling and exciting in different
ways we're going to hear from Pat about
his trip to Colombia no joke there and
um so many other things but if you paid
attention at all to the news over the
Thanksgiving holiday you certainly must
know by now that you must bow down to
the Omicron covid variant never leave
your house again hide from this brutal
deadly variant which will kill everyone
and destroy the economy for well hold on
a second let's actually back up for a
bit is it possible it will be that bad
yes at any point we don't want to
belittle the fact that the possibility
that we could get an extremely deadly
variant but the story that has been more
or less the corporate media story so far
starting on Friday
which by the way led to the worst day
for stocks of the year as a result of
the panic with the Dow Jones Industrial
Average down more than two and a half
percent the Russell 2000 Index down
nearly four percent I mean just a
disastrous day for stocks on the basis
of Omicron what is the truth of it the
truth is we don't really yet know
almost anything about it that would lead
us to say this is it for being out of
our houses this is it for being able to
sort of be living mildly more normal
lives this is it for the economy we we
just the corporate media Panic which
affected the stock market was very much
ahead of itself and we're going to talk
about that so first let's talk about the
goods could the Omicron variant
um be more deadly than any other sure it
could
could the Omicron variant be more
transmissible sure it could be and that
may be the one element of it that we are
closest to knowing about at this point
in time it's possible that it's way more
transmissible does the Omicron variant
make the current vaccines useless it's
possible that that could be the case but
we do not know any of that right now and
the Panic is serving no one well now
there are some in the audience who might
say well the Panic is good because it's
getting people ready to
lockdown or whatever I I disagree I
don't think that the Panic at this point
absent actual information is doing
anybody any good so let's talk about
what we actually know about the new
variant first question
um is it uh well let's actually look at
um the possibilities of what it could be
and what we know so Dr Eric topel
tweeted over the weekend important
Message from Dr lascelles a leading
South African infectious disease
specialist now Dr laselles wrote quote
just the note of caution we know that
getting a rapid understanding of disease
severity with Omicron particularly in
vaccinated individuals and reinfections
is absolutely critical but it's just too
early for Reliable data
anecdotally we're hearing from some in
South Africa that Omicron variant
symptoms are quote unusual but mild but
that's not something to hang our hats on
yet either that could be because it is
more young people so far hit with this
variant in South Africa now
it's already all over the world
identified in Canada Germany Belgium
um Hong Kong the United Kingdom it's
probably in the United States says Dr
Anthony fauci so it's all we've seen
these containment measures basically
punishing southern Africa and
um it's already all over the place and
that doesn't seem to be doing too too
much but we do not yet know
uh whether the symptoms will be more
severe or more mild remember that in
general
coronaviruses tend to get more
transmissible and less severe over time
becoming a really spreadable cold can
take years can take years as Dr Vincent
raquinello told us the real headline
is not one that causes panic and clicks
and stock market declines which is the
headline from science from this weekend
which is called very boringly patience
is crucial why we won't know for weeks
how dangerous Omicron is now one issue
is that Omicron is rapidly replacing
other variants in South Africa so that's
seen as a bad bad sign it's always very
quickly out competing other variants now
that's possible that it could be because
it's more transmissible and or more
serious it could also be due to chance
it could also be due to skewed testing
or a number of other things we don't
know yet
Omicron could evade vaccine immunity and
natural antibodies it could and that
would be terrible however the number of
mutations alone alone don't actually
tell us that
um but the general view so far is that
if you have been vaccinated or recovered
naturally from a previous variant you
would likely have some protection
against Omicron we don't yet know how
much there might be a drop it could be a
bigger drop than with other variants we
don't know now we got an update this
morning from The Who and the who is
being very clear about all the things we
do not know quote it is not yet clear
whether Omicron is more transmissible
it is not yet clear whether infection
with Omicron causes more severe disease
compared to Prior variants
preliminary evidence suggests there may
be an increased risk of reinfection with
Omicron compared to other variants we
don't yet know same with vaccines we
don't yet know that's the update as of
just an hour ago so in all seriousness
let's not ignore this I am not saying
don't worry about it guys let's wait and
see and in the meantime let's behave
logically for the circumstances and
facts that we know last thing CEO Albert
borla from Pfizer
says Pfizer has already started to
develop a new coveted vaccine
tailored to the Omicron variant take a
look at this when it comes to the
vaccine
remains to be seen I don't think that
the result will be uh
uh the vaccines don't protect I think
the results could be which we don't know
yet but the vaccines protect less which
means that if the vaccines protect less
it is that uh if we need to create a new
vaccine already we started Friday Friday
we made our first DNA template which is
the first part of the manufacturing of
the development process of a new vaccine
and we have made multiple times clear
but we will be able to have a vaccine in
less than 100 days in fact we have
already two vaccines built in less than
100 days so you know we keep hearing
this kind of hundred day number moderna
has said something similar so that's
something that is being worked on but
let's go by what the data shows and so
far what the data shows is there's three
or four very important questions that we
are asking and which need to be answered
about this variant we do not yet have
those answers and I think it's important
that we not lose our minds until we
actually do get those answers if you
think we should be panicking already uh
then let me know but I think it's uh
let's take it a step at a time as many
of you know I always prefer to do there
has been speculation and questions as to
whether Joe Biden will run for
re-election in 2024
now you already you may know my position
on this already and my position on this
is that I see a Joe Biden re-election as
a very tough uphill battle and I see a
Kamala Harris replacement of Joe Biden
as the Democratic nominee in 2024 as a
very tough uphill battle now sometimes
people will write to me and they'll say
David are you saying that so that people
don't rest on their Laurels and tune out
or are you saying that are you
overstating that or
I'm not gaming anything I am just giving
my honest opinion my genuine opinion it
doesn't mean I have someone I think
would do I have no I have There's No
Superstar right now in the Democratic
party that I love and I feel super
inspired by uh I don't have any better
Alternatives at this point to Biden and
Harris I'm just saying I see the
re-election uh Hill as a very steep one
for both Joe Biden and Kamala Harris the
White House has put out a statement
saying Joe Biden intends to run in 2024
and this created so many headlines of
people saying he's running he's running
and I think you have to understand that
there is one important word in this
headline and that word is intense it is
intense and what one intends to do in
2021 10 months into their presidency can
have absolutely no connection whatsoever
to what one actually does in 2024. uh
CNN summarizing the article saying the
White House said on Monday that Joe
Biden intends to run for re-election in
2024 following a recent report
indicating that the commander-in-chief
and staff are attempting to assuage
concerns about his future political
prospects when White House Press
Secretary jensaki was asked to board Air
Force One whether she could confirm if
he was going to run in 2024 and whether
he was telling staff that she responded
Yes that's his intention The Washington
Post reported Biden and members of his
inner circle have been telling allies he
plans to run again and attempt to
address concerns about whether he could
commit to another presidential campaign
given his age a recent Quinnipiac poll
showed Biden's approval rating sits at
36 percent now very important to
remember that if you actually look at
the 538 Biden approval it's actually not
much changed from where it was it's
still at 43 and it's been there
basically going all the way back to a
month ago so although it is true that
there is a Quinnipiac poll showing Biden
at 36. on average there's been no
movement for a month or maybe even like
five or six weeks that doesn't mean
Biden's approval rating is particularly
good right now
um but the 36 percent number is very
much an outlier so this entire story
is about the word intense
intents can have a very different
meaning if things change or if whatever
happens if you said today David sir even
money bet no odds just D if you you all
you have to bet on is does Biden run or
does Biden not run
I would take the even money bet on Biden
does not run for re-election it's not by
much right now I would say I'm
55-45 maybe 60 40 that Joe Biden does
not run for re-election in 2024. we
don't know to I know people were right
we'll write in and say David you're
wrong
it's an odds prediction for which I
marginally feel more confident that
Biden doesn't run it's not like a big
claim I'm not saying that it's a
statement of fact it's a statement of
opinion because it's in the future
and I'm saying 55 45 or 60 40.
um I want to hear from you really about
two questions question one is and you
can you can let me know on Twitter at D
Pacman question one is
will he run what do you think question
two may be the more important question
is if he runs what exactly is the path
to re-election because I see it as very
very tough particularly when the out
party tends to have higher enthusiasm we
have this Cult of Q slash Trump which is
still very very strong and I think
um I mean listen to
there a lot of the motivation for voting
Biden in 2020
was to get rid of Donald Trump that was
a worthy motivation I'm not that was my
motivation among other things
we had to get rid of trump with Trump
gone the early signs are it is tougher
to get Democratic voters motivated and
so I am worried about Biden's path to
victory in 2024 if he's the candidate of
course if he's better than the
alternative we don't know who that will
be yet might be Trump might be someone
else I will say we've got to vote for
Biden okay I'm still as pragmatic as
ever uh but I'm curious to hear from you
find me on Twitter at dpacman we'll take
a quick break and continue getting
caught up from the long holiday weekend
right after this short break
one of our sponsors is Disco there are
so many different types of bogus skin
care products for men out there what you
really want to go with is just something
affordable effective and created by
dermatologists that's why we have disco
which delivers the science-backed
over-the-counter skin treatments that
dermatologists recommend to their
patients every day the Disco Starter Set
is a simple way to take care of your
skin in three quick steps the face
cleanser stick fights oily skin the
exfoliating face scrub prevents razor
burn and the face moisturizer keeps your
skin hydrated disco can also help with
ingrown hairs dry skin acne and other
things you just need 60 seconds a day
I've been using it for a while now I'm
seeing a noticeable difference maybe you
can even tell check out disco try out
the products for yourself you will like
the results and you'll get 30 off when
you go go to
let'sdisco.com Pacman or just enter the
code Pacman the link is down below I
want to remind everybody that on
December 14th we've scheduled the next
David Pacman show viewer Town Hall the
first one was incredible I think we had
hundreds of people call in we took close
to I think a hundred different questions
and comments from audience members um it
will be 6 p.m Eastern Time 3 P.M Pacific
on December 14th it will stream live if
you want to watch it on the Pac-Man Live
YouTube channel that's our second
YouTube channel you can find it at
youtube.com Pacman live everybody's
welcome to call in
but we will give priority on the call
line to our website members grab a
membership at joinpakman.com not only
will you get priority on our town hall
you will also get a daily bonus show you
will get commercial free audio and video
streams of the show and so many other
great things so sign up today join
pacman.com so we talked at the beginning
of the show we had this crazy weekend
including the biggest stock decline of
the year on Friday due to the fears and
panic over the Omicron variant as I
already said we don't yet know a long
list of important things that we at some
point will know about the Omicron
variant but needless to say it caused
panic and sell-offs in the stock markets
it also created an environment over the
weekend on right-wing media for an even
bigger scale up of covet and vaccine
disinformation now you might be saying
well hold on how could there be more
disinformation on covet and on vaccines
they've been doing it for close to two
years it's still getting even worse it
continues to get worse and worse and I'm
going to go through a couple of these
instances with you and we'll talk about
some of the the points that are being
made now in the context of Omicron
Republican Congresswoman Nancy mace was
interviewed on Fox News and her idea was
hey you know what maybe instead of
vaccines people should get sick with
covid because you are better protected
this is something they've been saying
for a while take a listen to this and
see if you can figure out why it's
dangerously irresponsible as in one of
the things that the CDC has not done and
no no policy maker at the federal level
has done so far is taken into account
what natural immunity does and that may
be what we're seeing in Florida today in
some studies that I've read natural
immunity gives you 27 times more
protection against future covid
infection than a vaccination and so we
need to take all of the science into
account and not now 20 she says 27 times
I haven't even been able to find a study
that asserts that I found one study that
says recent recovery gives you 27
percent better protection than the
vaccines which are tailored to the
original variants the best is still
recovery plus vaccine and remember the
vaccine won't kill you whereas getting
coveted to end up with immunity might
actually kill you selectively choosing
what science to follow when we are
making policy decisions and you're
seeing I believe Governor DeSantis is uh
you know seeing the fruit of that labor
today okay yeah the sand this has
actually done everything wrong on covid
but again even if it were true that
you're more robustly immune by
recovering rather than getting
vaccinated the process of recovering
naturally can kill you at close to a one
percent rate whereas what we know about
the vaccines is there are three people
who died from myocarditis
after being vaccinated it may have been
related and there have been hundreds of
millions of people in the U.S vaccinated
already so it's incredibly irresponsible
to say
for Jesus it's 27x even if it's 27 that
go through a process through which
nearly one percent will die to get
immunity rather than getting a shot very
very irresponsible and then lastly
recovered or not there's sort of like a
a game theory there's an optimal
solution
um to this which is
if you haven't recovered from the virus
you want to get the vaccine to develop
immunity if you have recovered from the
virus you get the vaccine and you get
even better immunity so either way you
get better immunity when vaccinated
incredibly irresponsible and dangerous
comments from Nancy mace then we go to
Donald Trump Jr
Donald Trump Jr is saying two things
which are crazy one is that nobody's
talking about the violent protests riots
anti-vaccine around the world that's
wrong I did an entire segment about it
last week it is being discussed and
number two he seems to think that we
should be having that here in the United
States go left so you don't hear about
about these policies you know you don't
hear about what's going on as it relates
to the riots in Europe on a daily basis
now against the vaccine mandates because
our media wants to block that out
they're going to make sure that you
never hear about it because they don't
want you getting these kind of ideas
that freedom may actually still exist in
some parts of the world I mean Europe is
pushing back and America's sitting there
like sheep uh you know this is great
we'll just go along think about what
he's saying he's saying they're he's
saying riots are good remember in other
contexts riots are bad and they can be
used to justify shooting people taking
out guns police being harsh with
protesters unless the writers or
trumpists in which case it wasn't a ride
at all it was antifa and peaceful
but here he's saying there's riots going
on in Europe against the vaccines and
those are good and the media isn't
telling Americans about them because
Americans might realize hey we should do
that here and he says that would be a
good thing he thinks there should be
riots it would be good to have riots
here in the U.S
um next Lara Logan was on Fox News and
she I mean see if you can find the
number of lies in this statement and
again this is all the context is
reporting about Omicron Alias if you
look at Sweden with no lockdowns and no
vaccinations and look at the death rate
there over time what they're realizing
is they can't joke okay so there are
it's nine seconds guys and she's lying
to you three times first of all no
lockdowns in Sweden in Sweden without
making it
policy of the state you had the sort of
Sheltering or separation
voluntary of uh the most vulnerable
swedes that's number one but it is true
that bars stayed open and okay that that
is true she says there's no vaccinations
in Sweden Sweden has more people
vaccinated than the US by percentage
right in the U.S we're at 59 fully
vaccinated in Sweden they're at 68 fully
vaccinated she's lying she said no
vaccines in Sweden reality more vaccines
in Sweden than the in the United States
and she says look at the death rate the
death rate in Sweden has started to
creep up creep up creep up and it's not
looking good in Sweden anymore it's a
very strange idealization of Sweden
based on lies we'll get back to Lara
Logan here's Stephen Miller former Trump
advisor who says you know if Trump were
in office we would already have modified
vaccines to deal with the new variants
which isn't true I mean just listen to
what the pharmaceutical companies are
telling us
president Trump was still in office by
the way we'd already have modified
vaccines to deal with the new variants
which is a great Point president Trump
bought us brought us vaccines in Record
Times which he made voluntary
non-mandatory and he'd have updates too
okay there is no evidence whatsoever
that we would already have modified
vaccines for the variants at this time
if Trump were president and the most you
know the funniest part of it is I guess
now vaccines are good again right when
you can attach them to accomplishments
of trump or imaginary accomplishments of
trump the vaccines are good other times
they placate to the most radical
anti-vax people uh on the Trump side
here's an interesting one here's a fox
guest who the the discussion is Omicron
and he is able to use this to talk about
non-existent voter fraud in the last
election how do I don't know how they
managed to do it but they do okay
um the benefit of of covet for the
Democrat Party they won the last
election action based on cobit they're
able to change election rules so it made
it far easier to cheat and potentially
steal you know different uh portions of
the electorate in the last election
was stolen hold on a second so hold on
do I do I think there was cheating in my
state of Wisconsin hell yes there was
cheating um that would have been a
change results I don't know you don't
know or you know because I didn't say I
didn't say it changed the election
results I said we'll fight about this in
the break he kind of just did he said I
don't know if it would have changed the
election results and of course there was
no evidence that anecdotal all the
things that always happen when 160
million people vote uh would have
changed the results in even a single
County never mind a single state so
making taking the Omicron opportunity to
talk about the big lie and then this is
completely off the rails we're going
back to Lara Logan
who has gone off the deep end
politically
she tells a story about how
there are Corona hundreds of
coronaviruses in Bones which is related
to her having bone cancer which isn't
funny but it's not even clear what
argument she's trying to make and
basically saying don't even try to
sequence variants like it's just it's a
crazy crazy thing and you can see the
doctor on the right side of the screen
starts to look a little bit confused
judge if they by the way that doctor is
the one who I guess talked to Trump
about his cognitive test he's a wacky
doctor and even he finds this nuts
testing for different strains of
coronavirus we're going to be locked
down for the rest of our existence I am
you know I had cancer my oncologist is a
specialist in bone cancer and he you
know every oncologist who deals with
bone cancer identifies hundreds of
coronaviruses inside of our bones
they've created a problem that can never
actually be solved so they can justify
whatever it is they want to do and if
you look around you everything is
falling apart even the the vote audits
are going ahead Durham is moving ahead
over time people can see that the
vaccines have nothing to do with Trump
or left or right many black people don't
want to get vaccinated you cannot
justify by the way that's being repeated
but it is not black folks who have the
lowest vaccination rate it's Trump
Republicans losing three to five
thousand border patrol agents twelve
thousand
Lou and even and of course it's not the
death rate of flu it's about six times
that flu death rate is about 0.15 covet
death rate is somewhere between 0.7 and
0.8 so that's very much untrue this is
lethal Americans have the right under
the Constitution to their civil
liberties and they can only be suspended
temporarily and for it to be local this
is not totally and completely Bonkers
now the one thing that is true about
coronaviruses and Bones is that covid
can affect bone growth in people who
have not reached their uh full size so
to speak and can affect bone density
there are studies about that so it seems
getting covered is potentially really
bad for the bones and we'll we're still
learning more about that so how long is
this stuff going to go on because at
every time that there's something new
with the pandemic they go back to the
same things the vaccines are probably
not so good good
guidelines are definitely bad Trump
would have done everything better and
somehow with with some cases it's let's
go back to the the voter fraud that they
claim stole the election from Trump
in 2020. it's the same Playbook just
getting recycled over and over again
truly living in a fantasy world I don't
want to spend a lot of time on this next
story but I do want to mention that
um what were originally subtler attacks
on Dr Anthony fauci the head infectious
disease doctor in the United States when
Trump was president
Trump started having disagreements with
Dr Anthony fauci
about all things covid and it started a
little bit of like an under belly of
people online and others starting to
attack Dr fauci this has now gone fully
mainstream within the Republican Party
um Senator Rand Paul one of the figures
that has been very publicly attacking Dr
fauci and most recently Senator Ted Cruz
remember Cancun Cruz he now has said
that Dr fauci should be prosecuted
prosecuted Dr fauci was asked about this
I don't know if it's that the the
pandemic itself has him sick of all this
nonsense I don't know if it's you know
he's an 80 year old guy maybe he's close
to retirement and he just doesn't care
anymore but he did not pull any punches
here on Ted Cruz and good for Dr fauci
take a listen to this
so anybody who spends lies and threatens
and all that theater that goes on with
some of the investigations and the
congressional committees and the Rand
polls and all that other nonsense that's
noise Margaret that's noise I know what
my job is Senator Cruz told the Attorney
General you should be prosecuted yeah
I have to laugh at that
I should be prosecuted what happened on
January 6th Senator wow
do you think that this is about making
you a scapegoat to deflect of course
president Trump of course you have to be
asleep not to figure that one out well
there are a lot of Republican Senators
uh taking aim at this I mean that's okay
I'm just gonna do my job and I'm going
to be saving lives and they're going to
be lying it seems another layer of
danger to play politics around matters
of life and death right exactly exactly
and to me that's that's unbelievably bad
because all I want to do is save
people's lives and I mean anybody who's
looking at this carefully realizes that
there's a distinct anti-science flavor
to this so if they get up and criticize
science nobody's going to know what
they're talking about but if they get up
and really aim their bullets at Tony
fauci well people could recognize
there's a person there so it's easy to
criticize but they're really criticizing
science yeah and um you know there are
people who are reacting to this by
saying oh it's it's inappropriate
imagine people caring now about what's
appropriate it's inappropriate for a
medical official to criticize a senator
well is it appropriate for senators to
attack a public health official all
along dating back to the Trump era
because what he said conflicted with the
non-science blabber of trump because
Trump wanted to make everything seem
less serious
and if you listen to what Dr fauci was
saying you would you would have no other
conclusion then wow if Dr fauci's saying
this this must be pretty serious while
Trump said our 15 cases are soon going
to be zero maybe one of the dumbest
statements ever made by a president in
history give me a break now they care
about what's appropriate so good for Dr
fauci good for Dr fauci you know we
don't know how long he's going to want
to keep working at this point he has
been doing this for decades and is 80
and if I were him I would be very sick
of what's going on but he seems
determined to keep doing what he can to
save lives and of course he should be
commended for that but the way in which
people like Ted Cruz are attacking him
is absolutely disgusting and he is uh he
seems to be as sick of it as I would be
at least we'll have more clips from this
interview on our Instagram you can find
the David Pacman Show Instagram at
davidpackman show follow me on Instagram
at david.pakman
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
all right so as we went into the long
Thanksgiving weekend in the United
States Donald Trump gave an interview to
Fox News prop again this Sean Hannity
and I think this interview is
interesting because if uh there I I'm
worried there are already some people
becoming desensitized to how horrible it
was under Trump we were some people are
already starting to forget and saying ah
I don't know Biden's not super exciting
and was Trump really that bad and it's
very very concerning and what is notable
about this interview is the degree to
which Donald Trump's same old lies are
being repeated but made even worse and
whether where his same terrible
instincts are being escalated and blown
up even further just look at this first
clip Trump with further lies further
lies about gas prices two weeks ago we
looked at a different interview Trump
did where he lied about gas prices to
some degree he's now lying even more and
being even more deceptive about this
issue take a listen to this a guess was
that a gasoline a dollar 83 or a dollar
86 when I left a gallon and now it's at
seven dollars and seventy cents in
California in different places in
California and it's heading that way
everywhere and it's going to go a lot
higher than that and we're asking OPEC
yeah so as I told you two weeks ago the
real price when Trump uh a year ago um
when Trump left
was 220 a gallon 220 a gallon not a
dollar eighty or 83 or 86 or a dollar 78
so the gas price was higher
um when Trump when Trump now says and
it's 770 in California again I wasn't
able to find any place where it was 770
in California I've heard anecdotally
that's super premium sometimes is in
certain places seven bucks a gallon in
California most people don't use super
premium the average price in California
is actually 470. so Trump is lying it's
just lie upon lie upon lie Trump then
again went back to this thing about Mark
Zuckerberg wanted goodies from him we
still haven't really figured out what
that means but Trump keeps saying it and
uh you watch what happens I think big
things are going to happen actually Sean
but he would often come to the White
House trying to get goodies he didn't do
too well
you you have so the context here is
Zuckerberg is bad because Facebook
banned Trump for regularly flouting and
violating their terms of service and
Trump now says on the one hand they they
suppress my speech but then Zuckerberg
came to me asking for stuff now is it
possible that Zuckerberg went to Trump
asking for stuff oh oh I'm almost
positive I mean I can't imagine anybody
who runs a company that big who given
the opportunity to speak to a president
wouldn't try to Lobby on the behalf of
things that would be good for them
um but that routine it's all personal
for Trump it's all pers it's not about
what is the best infrastructure for
social media for the country
and what could I do in my meetings for
Mark Zuckerberg to do good things it's
Zuckerberg banned me but he asked me for
stuff it's all me me it's all personal
Trump then now this is fascinating he
shifts an old talking point to now
generally apply to supply chains check
to see if you notice the talking point
and we did a fantastic job in supplying
our country every shelf was Bare every
cupboard I call them the cupboards were
bare for the different states we did a
great job we got no recognition now you
might remember that the cupboards were
bare is a phrase trump used to only
apply to what he said was the bear
cupboards of the military
Trump would say I came in Obama left the
cupboards bear in the military we had no
weapons he's a sir they they came to me
they said sir we got no ammunition and
then I got ammunition now Trump is just
generally applying the cupboards were
bare to States supply chain products
whatever
it's the same talking point now just
applied to something different and it's
always been a lie then Trump starts to
try to rewrite history
Trump raises the idea that the capital
riots on January 6th those weren't Trump
supporters that was antifa but they go
after people that in many cases and not
in all cases but in many many cases are
Patriots and you had some bad people and
if you look at what happened at the
Capitol you had some bad people that
were not Patriots at all and they came
from other places including antifa and
including others and they let a lot of
people astray they don't want to cover
that yeah I like how he says antifa
antifa
um so that Trump is saying two things
his supporters who are not criminals
their Patriots aren't being treated well
and the truth that a lot of the rioters
were antifa is not being covered and
those people are not being prosecuted
there's no evidence for any of this this
is lies all the way down I hope that you
know that maybe the funniest moment from
this interview is Trump says finally the
Durham report is out it's not and
Hannity goes but it's not out and it's
just a delightfully confusing moment
here on on the Hannity Show interesting
uh the Durham report as far you know
it's come out I wish it could have been
a little earlier but it's unbelievably
completed I would imagine it's just not
even out yet but I want to ask you about
that stuff I mean no but the foundations
debunked
that's the best uh Hannah he doesn't
know and he says but it's not even out
and Trump says no well but the
foundations are being built is it just
total confusion and then maybe my
favorite lie that was the funniest
moment but my favorite lie is when Trump
says he created the term fake news now
I'm going to address they are and I say
it and I don't want to say it much but I
say it and I hope in the future I won't
have to they are the enemy of the people
and we could have a country that would
be able to heal and get together except
the media foments it they're so corrupt
and you know I called it I came up with
the term fake news a long time ago I
don't know if I'll get credit for that
but that's okay well you won't get
credit for it because you didn't come up
with the term what and it now this is
this is super interesting the term fake
news has been around a really really
long time and it has a specific meaning
like the original fake news was Hillary
Clinton birthing an alien baby or
something like that I'm not saying
that's the first fake news story but it
referred to like tabloid fake news later
in the Advent during the after the
Advent of online news
fake news was used to refer to the same
type of stuff but online just totally
made up stories Trump didn't invent the
term fake news what Trump pioneered was
calling any reporting you don't like
fake news that's Trump's contribution
it's a very negative contribution then
they go on to dementia and cognitive
tests and Sean Hannity still talking
about Trump passing his dementia test
you took that cognitive test I asked
Ronnie Jackson you got 30 out of 30. do
you believe that Joe Biden is showing
signs of being cognitively compromised
and should he take the test look all I
can say is I know president XI I know
out Putin I know Kim Jong-un I know all
the leaders of the world I got to know
him very well most of my life many of my
like although tough cookies they're all
at the top of their game we need
somebody that's at the top of the game
and you know maybe you should it should
be mandated that you take like cognitive
tests or something yes we've been saying
that for a long time but the the
Montreal cognitive assessment uh would
just be one layer we would hopefully
have more actually and that is what
Trump seems very confused about maybe
like cognitive tests or something and
then lastly
um Trump says in reaction to the
Waukesha tragedy where this individual
ran over multiple people killing I think
the death toll is now tragically up to
six Trump says there is good news there
which is the guy hated Trump
the good news is he hated Trump okay he
hated Trump based on early
that's the good news guys the guy hated
Trump so another I mean you couldn't get
an easier interview from Sean Hannity
and even Sean Hannity can't save Donald
Trump for making a fool out of himself
now
this is not only about criticizing
things Donald Trump said we are now
going to talk about things Hillary
Clinton said which
don't make a whole bunch of sense uh
they make a little sense but not that
much Hillary Clinton over the last week
or so has really been talking a lot
about cryptocurrency she's very
concerned about cryptocurrency and she
stumbles across a whole bunch of things
that make no sense and a couple that do
now I'm going to remind everybody my
view on cryptocurrency I'm not some big
crypto
Maven and I'm also not against it in
principle I believe that like every
other Financial instrument stocks bonds
real estate precious metals
foreign
cryptocurrency is a tool there are some
who say it's not really an asset class
because it's gambling or whatever okay
listen I mean at this point it seems
pretty clear that at least for the
foreseeable future crypto is here to
stay uh I have said that my decision
years ago was to get about three to five
percent exposure to cryptocurrency
because it's done so well it keeps
becoming a bigger and bigger portion of
my assets and I then sell it down and
move into things that I consider to be
less volatile it's a tool like any other
and there are pros and cons like with
everything else let's listen to the
first clip here this is from The Rachel
Maddow Show and listen very carefully to
what Hillary Clinton says I want to
mention one other thing that um
is on the horizon that people are only
beginning to pay attention to and that's
the need to regulate the cryptocurrency
markets because imagine the combination
of social media uh the algorithms that
drive social media uh the amassing of
even larger sums of money through the
control of certain cryptocurrency uh
chains uh we're looking at not only
states such as China or Russia or others
manipulating technology of all kinds to
their advantage we're looking at
non-state actors either in concert with
States or on their own
destabilizing countries destabilizing
the dollar as the reserve currency there
are so many uh big questions that the
Biden Administration must address I just
don't think we have much time and
therefore I hope from everything I'm
hearing from them that that's exactly
what they're going to try to to do now
there are little bits and pieces of
reasonable stuff there mixed in with a
lot of very strange claims this was the
second time in this short period of time
that Hillary talked about
cryptocurrencies she also spoke remotely
at a Bloomberg conference and she had
very similar comments to make take a
listen and then one more area
see because what looks like a very
interesting and and somewhat exotic uh
effort to uh literally mine uh new coins
in order to trade with them has the
potential for undermining uh currencies
for undermining the uh role of the
dollar as the reserve currency okay I'm
going to pause it there so first of all
she says you're you're literally mining
coins no it's metaphorical mining it's
computers doing stuff literally mining
is actually mining mining means mining
here what we're talking about is
computers solving cryptographic uh uh uh
problems uh doing crazy right
um it's it's not literally mining which
is just weird but at the end there's
something she mentioned twice which is
really what this is all about
um the idea that cryptocurrency might
challenge the status of the dollar as
the reserve currency now there's a lot
of confusion in there Hillary Clinton
rightly identifies that for example
there are ways in which countries could
and can use cryptocurrency to circumvent
economic sanctions that that's a that's
a legitimate problem it's a completely
legitimate problem and there are
proposed solutions to it but that's a
that's a real problem the backwards part
is the whole reason China doesn't want
crypto is because they manipulate the
Yuan and they don't want something they
can't control to become common okay and
so then you've got this idea of the
digital yawn and it's a complete and
total mess but it's it's kind of the
opposite like
China's trying to keep crypto out
in order to not even have the yawn
challenged but she says well they're
going to use Bitcoin or whatever
Mainline crypto
to try to destabilize the US dollar
which number one wouldn't be great for
China because they hold so much U.S debt
and number two China actually seems to
be going the other direction which is
just trying to ban crypto and it's
really an example of one of the top
skills of being a politician which is
speaking really really confidently about
something you don't fully understand she
sounds like she knows what she's talking
about and she comes stumbles across some
things that are real but then there's a
whole bunch of other stuff in there that
really doesn't make sense and it's
actually sort of surprising that the
handlers of which she has many did not
put together kind of more more coherent
talking points but maybe those are the
talking points that they actually want
now the other thing is there's always
this kind of alluding to cryptocurrency
being used for crime
a new report suggests about a third of
one percent of crypto transactions are
related to criminal activities I don't
think that's a very good argument
against crypto in in my mind
um but I think it's something we hear
frequently but really what this is about
is the US dollar as the world's Reserve
currency China holds a ton of it uh
Japan holds a ton of it although you you
much more rarely hear Japan mention
because they're not considered
adversarial in the same way
um but I think that listen I
ah how do I how can I say this it's
increasingly seeming to me like crypto
is here to stay
and seeing people blindly say it's bad
and I want nothing to do with it to me
seems more like digging one's head in
the sand rather than saying oh this is
now something that is going increasingly
mainstream let me give myself a little
bit of exposure to it and that's not
Financial advice for anyone in
particular it's just the story and my of
what I did in my thought process in the
three to five percent range for me
um and let's see what happens as part of
a diversified long-term approach to
financial assets and tools and at the
end of the day I see cryptocurrency as a
tool uh quite simply end of story let me
know your thoughts we'll take a quick
break and be back right after this
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show alright
let's look at a couple of other things
this is one of the wackiest wackiest
video clips I have seen in my entire
time doing this show this is a woman
we've spoken about before this is end
times preacher Sharon Gilbert now Sharon
Gilbert claims that an alien
imitated her husband
tried to have sex with her she figured
out the alien was actually xers
and somehow Jesus was a factor as well
and the alien was a reptile with
gargoyles now I'm going to play the clip
for you
we're not laughing at mental illness
we're not joking about mental illness
it's not funny
Mike serious question is isn't this very
serious mental illness where you would
say are you being medicated are you
under the care of a psychiatrist would
there be if this was not called
Christianity but just non-religious
delusions and it was your cousin doing
this wouldn't you say you should check
yourself into an ER maybe a psych hold
it's not a joke
why do they get out of just saying
being told you're sick because it's
under the guise of religion listen to
this after Derek and I got married
one night
this other Derek
appears in our bed
the real Derek is lying down next to me
other Derek sits right up out of him
it startled me
I knew that was not Derek
and so I asked this critter
who are you right because he clearly
wanted to have sexual relations
what happened to I have a headache and
you just leave it at that you know uh
you're not the real Derek You're an
Alien I mean it's a or did this guy get
caught masturbating by her and pretended
to be an alien I can't tell what the
real story is here
and I said and he said come on I'm your
husband I said who are you
and he had the nerve to claim to be
Eros Suarez
Xerxes Xerxes well other Derek seriously
wanted to invite me
to use my free will
to do something that was going to pull
me away from God by the way notice that
they are selling at the bottom of the
screen the great delusion DVD bundle it
seems to be just I wonder if it's just
delusions like this one
so this last time
I knew
he was really desperate yeah and I asked
him again who are you he told me the
same answer and I said he was really
desperate by now because the first time
she said you're not really Derek not
going with you this was an internal
dialogue finally I said I've had enough
yeah in my mind I reached up
I grabbed his face
and I said you are a liar
and Jesus is real and I pulled that face
off right and beneath it was a reptile
oof and he had little creatures with him
this time he brought these little
halfling creatures and they looked like
I don't know Gargoyles the guy's nodding
by the way there's two guys sitting next
to her and if you're not watching
they're nodding to everything she's
saying very reptilian as well so beneath
that face of Derek was a reptilian
Serpentine creature probably similar to
what was visiting the Anasazi you know I
continue to believe hey honey I'm really
tired tonight is probably still more
sensible but again if if this is real
and we're joking around about it if this
is really her belief
is this not a very very sick individual
and you have to remember that there's a
way you know it
they've created a layer of protection
for themselves where they go it's my
religious belief and many people when
they hear that they go oh okay let me
just and where is the line
Angels demons
Xerxes reptile was actually in the body
of my husband trying to have sex with me
what where is the line where we say lady
this is Bonkers we got to have you
evaluated you tell me you tell me where
that line is okay one more tour through
the Evangelical televangelist Insanity
throughout the pandemic televangelist
Kenneth Copeland has been
coming up with all sorts of bizarre
Rants and Raves about curing the
pandemic this way that the vaccines are
bad all these different things
this is a very weird clip where he
screams in order to kill the virus in
his colon he's talking about the flu
virus not I mean when you say in the
colon are we talking about viral
gastroenteritis it doesn't seem like it
take a look at this and by the way at
the bottom of the screen if you need him
to pray for you there's a number you can
call
I'm gonna help you here with something
yeah
in the name of Jesus
flu virus
die
in my colon
now
[Applause]
now
if Saturday Night Live which I don't
really find funny anymore was going to
parody this
how could they do it he's actually up
there saying die in my colon and the
congregation repeats die in my colon how
how do you make a joke how do you
satirize that it's impossible and the
important message here is that we should
all remember Kenneth Copeland's entire
grift is tax exempt because it's a
church his six plus million dollar house
where he lives with his wife Gloria
is exempt from property taxes how well
it's listed as a parsonage a parsonage
is a church house provided for a member
of the clergy sometimes you know like
the old Catholic Church down the street
has a parsonage and it's often sort of
like a very modest Department of some
kind his six million dollar house is tax
exempt from real estate taxes because
it's a parsonage he tried to get
tax-exempt status for his private jet
that was denied but he still has a
private chat it's just not tax exempt
and taxing churches would generate about
71 billion dollars per year if the
United States were to do that so that's
Kenneth Copeland
if you said behind the scenes hey I'm
gonna look at how look at how sheep uh
how much of a of a group of flock of
sheep I have out there I'm gonna go out
there and say die in my colon and
they're all gonna chant it with me
it seems like a joke it seems like a
joke but it's unfortunately very very
real we have a voicemail number and that
number is 219 to David P
as many of you know I've been saying for
since the start of the Kyle Rittenhouse
trial I believe not guilty will be the
verdicts and I got a very strange
voicemail over the weekend saying that I
was so wrong about the case that I
should expect to be sued by whom I don't
know but take a listen to this hey pack
boy I was just wanted to let you know
that you were wrong about writtenhouse
after all and I bet you're ready for the
losses that are coming up
of
so those polls that are showing Trump
being biting or not bogus they are
true because Biden is just as dumb as
you are bye this is a weird voicemail
because the the caller seems to think
I've said the opposite of what I've said
I've said since the start of the trial I
expect not guilty based on Wisconsin law
and the evidence and that's what we got
uh I don't know who would sue me or for
what
and I didn't say that the polls showing
Trump beating Biden are bogus I said the
pollster is not a historically reliable
poster Rasmussen but I also said I think
the general message that in a rematch of
2020 and 2024 Trump wins is accurate so
as usual criticize me for things I've
said
is that too much to ask not for things
you imagine I said or you heard on some
other channel or you wish I had said or
you misheard I said criticize me for
things I've said guys please we've got a
great bonus show for you today I will
tell my Thanksgiving stories producer
Pat will tell his Thanksgiving stories I
expect his will be more interesting
because he was in Colombia not Columbia
University the country Colombia where
you know that our caller Pedro from
Colombia where he's supposedly from so
Pat Will Tell Us those stories we're
also going to talk about uh this latest
attempt
where conservatives
how do I even they want to get Books
banned and the way they do it is they
organize to attack specific libraries in
the United States not physically
attacked to start sending in mass
communication
demanding certain books be removed to
make it seem like wow Grassroots effort
from parents here to remove certain
books this is the next sort of battle
line in the continued culture War which
is activating to get certain Books
banned from American libraries we'll
tell you who's doing it where it's being
done
etc etc sign up right now at
joinpakman.com to get access to the
world famous bonus show we will see you
then it's great to be back and we'll be
here all week
foreign
thanks a lot for watching Today's Show I
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors disco delivers
affordable science-backed skin care
treatments to your home the Disco
Starter Set helps guys fight oily skin
and razor burn and keeps your skin
hydrated I've had great results with it
you'll get 30 off at letsdisco.com
Pacman the link is down below